c'est l'heure du second débat de sens
publici direction l'Afghanistan 2 ans
après le retour des talibans au pouvoir
à Kabou une dictature religieuse qui
persécut ses opposants qui privent les
femmes de leurs droits fondamentaux un
régime que combat Hamad Massou le fils
du commandant assassiné en septembre
2001 Ahad Massou reçu au Sénat
aujourd'hui il est en visite en France
pour 10 jours et il appelle la
communauté internationale à l'aider dans
sa lutte contre les tyrans islamistes
Marion Vig et Samia de chirur rcrer ce
midi voici l'essentiel de leur
interview je pense qu'il est essentiel
que la communauté internationale
s'engage avec les forces démocratiques
afghan et ce pour faire pression sur les
talibans pour qu'un dialogue puisse
reprendre parce que ce régime illégitime
qui s'est imposé aux Afghans par les
armes et cette oppression qui s'exerce
ne sont pas
acceptables
et c'est une menace pour nous
tous vous avez rencontré le président du
Sénat vous étiez au Parlement européen
hier comment se sont passés les
échanges c'était peut-être la première
fois que nous sentions un tel changement
de
regard une telle bienveillance envers
l'Afghanistan et la situation des
Afghans je dis pas que ce n'était pas le
cas avant mais je crois qu'après 2 ans
les talibans montrent leur vrai
visage ils n'ont pas changé ils n'ont
pas tenu leurs
promesses et je sens qu'il y a une vraie
attention désormais de la part des
Européens et c'est un immense espoir
pour les Afghans et pour les forces
démocratiques du
pays mais vous ont-ils donné des preuves
de cet
engagement
je pense qu'on s'en approche mais
c'était vraiment des échanges positifs
et des échanges
constructifs vous voulez représenter la
résistance au taliban dans votre pays
avez-vous des soutiens et si oui combien
êtes-vous nous sommes 43 millions de
résistants les Afghans ne soutiennent
pas les
talibans si les taliban le pens je les
défi d'organiser des élections et nous
verrons bien qu' l'emporte
comme votre père vous ne vouliez pas
combattre mais à vos yeux vous n'avez
pas le
choix absolument les talibans refusent
de parler de négocier avec les
oppositions et les forces démocratiques
du pays pour trouver une sortie de
crise tout ce qu'il disent c'est
rendez-vous et tout ira bien pour
l'avenir de
[Musique]
l'Afghanistan
ce n'est pas une façon de parler donc
quand vous n'avez pas d'autre choix que
de vous défendre alors vous le
faites je suis sûr que cette oppression
aura une fin et que les Afghans seront
victorieux je veux juste faire mon
devoir protéger mon pays du mieux que je
peux le fils Massou peut-il représenter
un espoir pour l'Afghanistan faut-il
discuter avec les talibans quel est le
sort des femmes afghanes aujourd'hui on
répond à toutes ces questions avec
nos invités David Rigou rose bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes chercheur à
l'Intitut français d'analyse stratégique
et chercheur associé à Liris rédacteur
en chef de la revue Orient stratégique
Carole man bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi sociologue présidente de
fmeille d'une association qui a mis en
place des programmes d'éducation secrète
des filles en Afghanistan
depuis quelques années ça fait la chute
des Talibas ouais donc ça fait ça fait
longtemps Patricia lmonè bonsoir bonsoir
heureux de vous accueillir grand
reporteur spécialisté des relations
internationales et autrice de ce livre
au cœur du chos aux éditions to je suis
en train de le livre de lire bravo et
puis vous racontez vos vos grands
reportages à votre fils aussi toutes les
questions que les parents se posent sur
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire ou pas dire de
l'horreur du monde à ses enfants et il y
a évidemment plusieurs chapitres
consacrés à l'Afghanistan Tam tranui
bonsoir bonsoir Tam vous êtes resté là
et vous êtes éitoraliste politique on va
pas passer trop longtemps dans ce débat
sur la la visite du de du fils Massou en
France mais David irerose il lance un
appel à l' International qu'est-ce qu'il
peut espérer bah en en général il fait
effectivement il a fait une il fait une
tournée euh pour pouvoir
euh établir la légitimité de son combat
il était au Parlement européen avant de
oui c'est ça c'est une grande tournée
dans le monde occidental euh en c'est
d'une certaine manière ça fait écho à ce
qu'il avait eu avant il y a une
vingtaine d'années sur la stigmatisation
du danger euh représenté par par les
talibans le problème c'est que la
situation est pas du tout la même
d'ailleurs il demande pas des armes dans
les différentes interviews qu'il a qu'il
a accordé il insiste sur le la nécessité
de ne pas reconnaître le régime taliban
de manière officielle c'est c'est
vraiment le point sur lequel il insiste
et et de soutenir effectivement le la
légitimité du combat des droits de
l'homme mais c'est vrai que pour le
reste c'est extrêmement contraint parce
que sur le terrain il est son mouement
est quand même très réduit et il y a une
réalité aujourd'hui c'est effectivement
la chape de plomb des talibans depuis
août 2021 ouis Carol man je sais que
vous êtes assez critique concernant le
le le fils du commandant Massou peut-il
représenter un espoir pour l'Afghanistan
je ne sais pas parce que je peux pas
vraiment me prononcer tout ce que je
sais c'est que ce n'est pas forcément un
féministe on n' pas vu madame Massou
elle est bien cachée et puis parler des
droits des femmes comme ça bien mais je
n'ai pas vu de programme ou quelque
chose de plus ouvert et il y a aucune
femme dans son cercle non plus ce qui
n'est pas le meilleur des signes ouis
Patricia Lemmonier le le nom de Massou
il a toujours une aura en en France
comment est-il perçu ailleurs et
notamment en Afghanistan qu'est-ce qu'il
représente Massou en Afghanistan alors
c'est vrai que c'est un symbole mais
c'est un symbole pour nous et en
particulier pour les Français c'est il
incarne aux yeux des Français
effectivement de par son père h HM qui a
été assassiné il faut le dire hein par
par des militants extrémistes islamistes
et bien il incarne cette lutte contre un
islam obscurantiste et cetera alors que
justement comme vous le disiez je ne
crois pas du tout que la famille Massou
et et les et et la population très
souvent majoritaire en afghan en
Afghanistan et bien soit féministe ou se
battte pour le droit des femmes ça c'est
un autre sujet lui ce qu'il vient faire
c'est qu'il vient rappeler la lutte
contre l'obscurantisme il se il se il se
présente contre le représentant de ceux
qui veulent lutter contre
l'obscurentisme et comme aujourd'hui les
armes ne semblent pas pouvoir parler et
bien il demande effectivement une lutte
sur un plan diplomatique surtout ne les
reconnaissez pas dit-il alors justement
cette question diplomatique 2 ans après
céit 15 août 2021 je rappelle la date de
la prise de de Kabou Tam tranu est-ce
que il faut discuter négocier avec les
talibans oui c'est la grande question
est-ce que par avec le diable c'est
pactisé avec lui est-ce qu'on a envie de
parler avec un régime qui prive des
millions de femmes de petites filles de
leurs droits fondamentaux qui leur
interdit l'accès à l'université qui leur
interdit l'accès à l'emploi jusqu'au
salon de beauté la réponse elle est
immédiate elle est instinctive c'est non
mais est-ce que l'instinct est bon
conseiller dans cette situation là c'est
beaucoup plus nuancé il y a en tout cas
une certitude c'est que les Occidentaux
non'ont pas pour autant de leçons à
donner à l'Afghanistan on a vu le
résultat de 20 ans de présence militaire
cidentale de programmes internationaux
d'aide à la gouvernance d'assistance
post-conflit tout cela a vir au fiasco à
la corruption au rejet des Occidentaux
par toute une partie de la population
afghane venir donner la leçon on a donc
vu le résultat alors est-il possible de
condamner le régime taliban sans
condamner sa population c'est toute la
question aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs
peut-être la réponse c'est un peu la
situation actuelle l'état des relations
avec l'Afghanistan oui c'est intéressant
parce que tous les contacts n'ont pas
été coupés avec le régime de Kabul
écoutez euh ce que disait euh Joseph
Borel en août 2021 il disait les
talibans ont gagné la guerre donc nous
devrons parler avec eux afin d'engager
un dialogue aussi vite que nécessaire
pour éviter une catastrophe humanitaire
et potentiellement migratoire Joseph
Borel donc le chef de la diplomatie
européenne au moment où les talibans
viennent de prendre le pouvoir depuis la
communauté internationale a sanctionné
condamné ce gouvernement mais tous les
contacts ne sont pas coupés l'aide
humitaire occidentale a fait
discrètement progressivement son retour
tour rappelons qu'aujourd'hui sur 40
millions d'habitants en Afghanistan on
estime à 28 millions ceux qui ont besoin
d'aide et à 6 millions ceux qui sont
menacé de famine depuis décembre 2021 il
y a donc eu le retour de la Banque
mondiale le déblocage d'aide à l'ONU
d'aide européenne avec toujours ce même
crédau il faut que l'aide aille à la
population afghane et pas aux taliban et
surtout garder le contact parler ne vaut
pas reconnaissance officielle du régime
ceux qui ont émis l'hypothèse de la
reconnaissance ont d'ailleurs vite
rétropédalés exemple avec au mois
d'avril la vice-présidente secrétaire la
vice-serétaire Générale de l'ONU Amina
Mohamed qui s'exprimait devant des
étudiantes à
princon nous espérons que nous ferons
les petits pas pour arriver à la
reconnaissance des talibans est-ce
possible je ne sais pas une
reconnaissance de principe sous
condition voilà après cette prise de
parole et bien il y a eu 25 courageux
afghanes qui ont manifesté à Kabou
contre une reconnaissance internationale
du régime et l'ONU a dû faire une
explication de texte pour dire qu'il ne
s'agissait pas de se substituer aux
États qui sont seuls à pouvoir
reconnaître un pays mais je cite et là
c'est du langage vraiment de l'ONU
redynamiser l'engagement international
autour d'objectif commun vers un chemin
durable concernant la situation en
Afghanistan une phrase que le commun des
mortels ne comprend pas mais qui doit
être très éclairante pour les adeptes de
la diplomatie certainement d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qu'ils en disent les diplomate
de cette voilà on va éc on va voir ce
que dit par exemple un ancien diplomate
Jean-François catin c'est un ambassadeur
de l'Union européenne il vit depuis un
an à Kabou il a eu ses mots dans une
tribune un texte très personnel où il
écrit aujourd'hui je suis extrêmement
inquiet de l'isolement de l'Afghanistan
sur la scène internationale qui ne mène
qu'à plus de souffrance pour la
population afghane et un risque accru
pour la sécurité régionale et
international d'où ce plaidoyer de sa
part pour la diplomatie parler avec
l'ennemi comprendre ses objectifs ses
perceptions pour tenter de résoudre les
conflits l'un des premiers diplomates
l'inventeur l'un des inventeurs de la
diplomatie mackavel écrivait il y a si
loin de la matière dont on vit à celle
dont on devrait vivre qu'en étudiant que
cette dernière on apprend plutôt à se
ruiner qu'à se conserver certains n'ont
retenu de macavel que le macavelisme que
le cyisme mais avec les mêmes principes
voilà queon voit son loin un descendant
Jean-François catin qui plat lui au
contraire pour plus d'humanité merci Tam
Carol man est-ce que c'est illusoire
pour vous de vouloir discuter avec ce
régime avec les talibans même avec cet
objectif dont parlait Tam Tran
c'est-à-dire finalement aider la
population continuer d'aider la
population mais discuter de quoi c'est
ça la question parce que leur point de
vue est extrêmement clairire ils vont
pas changer les promesses on a vu ce que
c'était donc ça ne sert absolument à
rien quand à l'aide humanitaire faut pas
oublier que l'Afghanistan est un des
grands narco-états du monde c'est un
pays extrêmement
riche non seulement avec l'opium mais
maintenant avec des amphétamines ce
qu'on appelle en anglais crystal meth HM
ils ont des laboratoires c'est très
facile à produire très bon marché ils
sont les premiers producteurs au monde
bon il y a de la concurrence mais ils
savent faire et d'ailleurs je l'ai écrit
dans dans un AR oui mais pardon vous
interrompre factuellement cet argent
alors on va pas dire queil faudrait
utiliser l'argent du narcotrafic pour
nourrir la population mais il n'arrive
pas à la population 6 millions de
personnes qui souffent de famine donc on
va pas couper le le le tuyau de l'aide
humanitaire parce que l'Afghanistan est
un arcoétat oui non mais de plus de quoi
voulez-vous discuter avec un narcoétat
qui vient de de de euh mettre presque au
pouvoir celui qu'on a appelé le Pablo
Escobar de l'Afghanistan que l'Amérique
a relâché ils ont un carnet d'adresse
magnifique ils sont très équipés et et
de quoi ils vont parler avec nous donc
nous on va continuer avec l'aide
humanitaire le temps que ça marche mais
il faut pas attendre quoi que ce soit
des talibans c'est illusoir David R vot
votre avis là-dessus parce que si c'est
pas la démocratie c'est quoi c'est une
opération militaire on a vu ce qu'on
donné les les précédentes hein combien
de combien d'opérations combien de
soldats qui sont morts là-bas bref oui
on n pas envie d'y retourner clairement
hein donc alors les les P sont pas coupé
puis qu'il y a quand même l'aide
d'humanitaire notamment qui qui perdure
il y a près de 6 milliards euh alors il
y a il y a elle est détourné ou pas elle
est partiellement détourné oui
évidemment comme mais euh évidemment
c'est c'est je je comprends c'est le
constat c'est l'analyse mais cette
phrase est horrible mais je dirais
qu'elle l'était avant aussi c'est le
problème d'ailleurs elle n pas plus
maintenant qu'elle ne l'était avant et
et ça explique pour partie aussi le
résultat actuel donc c'est c'est très
compliqué parce qu'effectivement on est
pris dans un dilemme on peut pas
abandonner un pays je veux dire à la
famille et en même temps il faut être
très circonspect sur sur les
laallocation des fonds qui sont donnés
évidemment d'autant plus qu'il y a en
arrière-pl effectivement cette question
de la drogue alors pour ce qui est de de
l'opium il y a eu une interdiction en
avril 22 he qui a été faite par le
commandeur des croyants entre guillemets
qui est relativement efficace parce que
effectivement il y a une mutation au
niveau du marché de la drogue avec avec
une plante qui pousse assez bien sur les
hauteurs qui s'appelle des fra et qui
donne effectivement qui est à la base
qui est un précurseur naturel et non
chimique mais des du christialm
métaamphétamine donc c'est le cynisme
absolu on donne l'impression qu'on
interdit le la drogue mais en fait on en
fait une autre quoi bien sûr parce que
là effectivement euh l'argent est
toujours le ner de la guerre d'une d'une
manière ou d'une autre donc on retrouve
les travers qui avaient été stigmatisés
précédemment mais de toute façon la
réalité objectivement c'est la main mise
des talibans sur le pays et personne
n'est prêt à revenir donc dans un une
configuration comme ça la question elle
est posée et on voit bien qu'il y a les
talibans jouent aussi là-dessus il
instrumentalisent puisque notamment avec
la Chine il Paris sur la Chine qui vient
d'envoyer un ambassadeur et des liens
chinepakistan justement pour promouvoir
une possibilité de normalisation au
niveau diplomatique alors justement ça
c'est intéressant aussi Patricia lesmè
ils sont pas aussi isolé qu'on peut
l'imaginer les les les taliments sur la
scène internationale non ils sont pas
aussi isolés ils ont effectivement le
Pakistan depuis toujours l'Iran la Chine
il y a une réunion il y a pas très
longtemps en Russie pour discuter de
l'avenir effectivement des relations
avec l'Afghanistan mais moi je suis
moins pessimiste enfin c'est pas le bon
terme sur ce qui se passe sur un plan
économique en Afghanistan effectivement
dans les deux premières années tout de
suite ça a été catastrophique on on en
arrivait même à vendre des petites
filles vous voyez plus t ça mais euh le
PIB aujourd'hui remonte et l'argent
rentre dans les caisses des talibans
parce que les talibans sont des gens
sérieux ils ont parfaitement compris que
il fallait euh faire rentrer l'argent et
eux quand ils vont quand ils veulent
faire rentrer l'argent ils font rentrer
l'argent quand il y a des détournements
ils en autorisent certains mais pas tous
donc les l'argent rentre il y a l'impôt
islamiste il y a l'argent qui rentre
dans les caisses et il y a des
distributions qui commencent à se faire
donc leur Paris c'est d'avoir un peu
cette aide humanitaire pendant le temps
nécessaire et ils vont arriver à se
débrouiller ils veulent et donc ils ne
changeront pas et c'est en ça où je
partage votre avis parce que ils vont
avec le système qu'ils mettent en place
arrivver à s'en sortir tant avec l'aide
des Chinois des Pakistanais et l'argent
qui rentre mais l'argent rentre mais
carolman il rentre mais il n'arrive pas
à la population il arrive
maisis vous entendre je vous redonner la
parole juste après patri je ne pense pas
que ça arrive à la population il se
disent de toute façon l'aide humanitaire
s'en occupera et puis selon leur
doctrine c'est la volonté divine qui
veut qu'on crève de faim donc ça les
importune pas plus que ça sauf
éventuellement si ça a des touches de
prês dans leur famille et ainsi de suite
euh moi moi je je un régime veut
toujours survivre d'accord et donc à un
moment donné euh il peut pas se perd
permettre d'aller trop loin dans pas
dans l'oppression l'oppression militaire
c'est une chose mais dans la famine dans
dans dans dans toutes dans toutes ces
chosesl parce que ça sort après quand on
n peut plus les gens sortent dans la rue
il peut pas donc ils vont se débrouiller
pour maintenir un niveau d'oppression et
en même temps pour
distribuer les les revenus qu'ils vont
tirer justement soit de la
métamphétamine soit et cetera soit soit
de tout il y a des gens qui ont encore
de l'argent
donc il leur impose même des retraits
d'argent donc euh ils veulent durer
c'est ça leur truc ok on va ouvrir un
chapitre important sur les conditions
des femmes et on va y consacrer de
longues minutes évidemment dans ce débat
mais un dernier mot peut-être sur
l'aspect on va dire un peu diplomatico
économique la la la Chine qu'est-ce qui
intéresse les Chinois en terme de
ressources de il y a il y a deux aspects
il y a les ressources effectivement les
mine notamment de cuivre le lithium on
dit que enfin il y a un rapport
américain des années 2000 qui évoquit le
l'Afghanistan comme un nouveau scandale
géologique parce que c'est il y a un
nombre de ressources minières absolument
faramineuses donc les Chinois on ont
préempé sur le le cuim une qui s'appelle
AAC il y a aussi un les compagnies
pétrolières qu qui viennent de signer
qui ont des accords sur pétrole et gaz
et puis il y a surtout le tronçon en
fait ils ont intégré récemment
l'Afghanistan dans les nouvelles routes
de la soir alors de manière marginale
parce que c'est pas le tronçon initial
le tronçon initial il parle de xingyang
et il débouge sur le port de guadar au
Pakistan mais avec un détour aujourd'hui
par l'Afghanistan évidemment c'est ce
que souhaite l'Afghanistan parce que ça
permet de l'intégrer dans le jeu
régional et dans ce grand cette grande
infrastructure justement chinoise dont
elle peut se prévaloir à ce moment-là en
terme de développement économique et de
et de pour attirer des capitaux allez on
ouvre ce chapitre consacré au aux droits
fondamentaux des femmes privées petit à
petit de ces droit et on va commencer en
regardant l'extrait d'un d'un
documentaire qui sera diffusé à la fin
du mois de novembre sur sur notre
antenne
documentaire qui s'appelle afghan tout
simplement on voit que les femmes sont
les premières victimes de la charia de
la loi islamique
regardez la charia punit aussi par
exemple les châtiments corporels doivent
être
appliqués la femme mariée qui commet
l'adultère doit être lapidée c'est écrit
ainsi et c'est la
loi
c'est dur je sais mais il est dit dans
le Coran que lorsque vous punissez ceux
qui ont commis des
péchés cela sert de leçons au reste du
peuple voilà à prop d'un juge dans un
tribunal de province extrait d'un
documentaire donc signé Soline chalvon
fioriti qui sera diffusé le 25 novembre
sur Public Sénat je propose à Maas de
nous rejoindre tout de suite puisque on
va grâce à vous Mathias
rebonsoir reprendre la chronologie
finalement du traitement réservé aux
femmes en Afghanistan depuis le retour
des taliban il n'aura pas fallu
longtemps pour que les droits des femmes
soient attaqués Kabou tombe Thomas le 15
août 2021 7 mois plus tard à peine en
mars 2022 première mesure terrible
l'accès à l'éducation est interdit aux
femmes dès l'âge de 12 ans dans un pays
où seulement 40 % des jeunes filles
seulement étaient scolarisé la mesure
est dévastatrice en décembre de la même
année c'est l'université qui ferme
formellement ses portes aux femmes avec
la possibilité d'être poursuivi
pénalement pour celles qui oseraient s'y
aventurer en 2021 on comptait tout de
même 100000 afghanes qui faisaient des
études supérieures un chiffre à présent
réduit au néant l'éducation n'est pas le
seul domaine ciblé par les talibans non
Thomas les talibans souhaitent tout
bonnement faire disparaître les femmes
de l'espace public mai 2022 le voile
intégral de préférence la bourka devient
oblig obligatoire selon les
recommandations de la charia novembre
2022 les parcs les jardins les salles de
sport et les bains publics leur sont
interdits enfin entre fin 2022 et mi et
mi-2023 c'est la quasi totalité des
entreprises qui leur ferment leurs
portes aujourd'hui en Afghanistan la
majorité des femmes n'a plus le droit de
travailler ce qui met en péril la
stabilité financière de beaucoup de
foyers dernière mesure en date à
l'encontre des libertés des femmes la
fermeture cet été et de manière
définitive de tous les salons de beauté
un véritable coou au moral pour les
femmes qui ne détenaient pratiquement
plus que ce lieu de socialisation en
dehors de leur domicile et ce traitement
pousse de plus en plus de femmes à
commettre l'irréparable évincé et
opprimé dans l'espace public les femmes
sont aussi victimes de violence une fois
la porte du foyer passé selon l'ONU 9
femmes sur 10 sont victimes de violence
familiale marié de force échangé contre
des dorrées alimentaires certaines de
plus en plus d'ailleurs comme vous venez
de l'évoquer Thomas font le choix du
suicide difficile d'avoir des données
précises toutefois puisque les talibans
ont interdit toute communication dans ce
domaine les seuls chiffres qui
parviennent à fuiter par les hôpitaux
publics ou les cliniques de santé
mentale sont très alarmants sur la
période 2021-2022 les femmes et jeunes
filles représentent les 3/4 des suicides
et des tentatives de suicide ce qui en
fait l'un des rares pays dans le monde
où les femmes sont plus nombreuses que
les hommes à attenter à leur jour merci
Mathias pour ces informations carolman
je me tourne vers vous peut-être
justement sur ce euh sur ces chiffres
qui sont par définition difficiles à
avoir vous qui êtes en contact avec
votre association famid avec euh des des
femmes afghanes euh ces tentatives de
suicide c'estes suicides il y en a il y
en a beaucoup y y a-t-il aussi et ma
question est double beaucoup de femmes
qui ont finalement choisi de s'enfuir
senfuir mais pour aller où ouis parce
que déjà elles n'ont pas le droit euh de
quitter leur foyer sans être accompagné
par ce qu'on appelle un Marram Marram
c'est euh un parent proche père père
frère cousin cousin germain euh et
encore et elles ont pas le droit d'aller
où que ce soit donc elles peuvent pas
partir s'enfuir où euh on a eu le cas de
personnes qui devaient venir en France
euh et même de de jeunes filles qui
avaient des euh qui avaient des bourses
d'études pour les pays du Golf elles ont
été interdites de prendre l'avion parce
qu'elles étaient pas accompagnées
c'était l'excuse officielle donc fuir
c'est c'est quasiment impossible et sur
les tentatives de suicide sur les
suicides ah oui oui oui oui c'est pas
nouveau je veux dire ça existait il y a
longtemps parce que d ça ex je veux dire
j'avais j'avais fait une enquête
là-dessus il y a plusieurs années
c'était à l'époque surtout des femmes
qui revenait d'Iran qui avait vu qu'il y
avait des alternatives et maintenant
avec les médias sociaux avec la présence
occidentale depuis 20 ans elle savent
que la vie n'est pas obligatoirement
celle à laquelle elles sont condamnées
résultat beaucoup de suicide Patricia
lémonère vous êtes allé en reportage je
le disais plusieurs fois en Afghanistan
dans dans votre livre au cœur du cou il
y a l'histoire de d'adolescente brûlé à
l'acide sur le chemin de l'école c'est
c'était quand comment vous les avez
rencontré euh c'était en 2007 au moment
où les Américains avaient décidé de
faire le sege de renforcer les le le
nombre de troupes parce que les talibans
en fait étit là et il y avait de
nombreuses attaques on et en particulier
dans la ville de kandard donc
effectivement nous sommes partis je suis
partie à candard l'équipe est resté à
Kabou donc j'ai pris une petite caméra
je me suis mis avec ma bourka et je suis
partie dans cette à la rencontre de ces
de ces jeunes filles et à l'époque il y
avait des gamines qui allaient à l'école
encore et et pourtant à Kandar les
talibans étaient là partout on était en
2007 on disait qu'il y avait les
Américains en fait ils sortaient de leur
base ils faisaient une opération mais la
nuit c'était déjà les talibans et et et
il voulait empêcher déjà les enfants les
gamines d'aller à l'école les jeunes
filles et donc il les vitriolent
c'estàdire qu'ils arrivaient en moto ils
jetaient des des des canettes de
vitriole sur elle et elle brûlaiit en
quelque sorte donc quand on dit euh euh
oh mais c'est terrible les taliban
qu'est-ce qu'ils font mais on ne pouvait
pas ne pas savoir ils ils étaient déjà
là quand on étai là h ils ils étaient
ils commettaient déjà toutes ces ces
horreurs quand ils étaient là donc je
crois que
c'est un mensonge de dire on est très
surpris de ce qu'ils font non on savait
tout c'était écrit c'était là et ça se
passait déjà dans toutes les campagnes
même dans une grande ville comme
Kandar David rigolerose ça veut dire
quoi que la communauté alors communauté
internationale c'est ça ve pas dire
grandchose c'est tellement voilà c'est
tellement vaste mais il y a en tout cas
peut-être les États-Unis l'Occident a
préféré quoi détourner le regard à un
moment bah à partir du moment où il y a
eu le choix du retrait de toute
façon quelle est l'alternative problème
euh on a considéré à tort ou à raison
que Ctait un échec alors c'est avec le
recul on jugera historiquement ça pas
tout à fait é un échec parce qu' il y a
quand même une génération de filles qui
est allé à l'école et ça reste ça reste
là euh donc c'est pas perdu mais
effectivement pour aujourd'hui la
situation est terrible d'ailleurs vous
évoquez les les les agressions mais il y
avait aussi le l'empoisonnement des
puits dans les écoles qui était fréquent
pour les justement pour dissuader les
parents d'envoyer les jeunes filles les
petites filles à l'école donc
aujourd'hui lui effectivement on est on
est un peu piégé par le le le ce qui ce
qui a été les les conséquences du
retrait qui a été acté et et aujourd'hui
le moyen de pression sur les talibans
bah il est quasiment quasiment nul sauf
éventuellement sur la question de la
reconnaissance et là comme vous évoquez
la communauté internationale en réalité
c'est une ternémologie qui est tellement
flou que parce qu'en réalité on pense
beaucoup pays occidentaux quand on parle
de et donc c'est et on VO
bienocentréç c'est trèsoc centré on voit
bien le le jeu qui n'est pas le même de
de la Russie de de la Chine et qui font
partie aussi de la communéé
internationale oui de l'Iran aussi vous
parliez Deiran alors que l'Iran
chite unite finalement ils
sentendent relation de la population
afghan avec les talibans est-ce que
enfin ça a été très facile pour eux
quand même de prendre le pouvoir en août
2021 est-ce que aujourd'hui il y a une
part d'acceptation il y a un rejet total
bien sûr on VO
a un fatalisme c'est qu'ils sont jamais
partis il faut savoir que ils étaient
dans le pays et peu à peu ils sont
arrivés à Kabul mais ils ne sont
absolument jamais partis a des régions
où ils ont été là de dès le départ du
Pay mais oui partout en province en
dehors des grandes V pardon mais ça veut
dire qu'il y a une partie de la
population afghane notamment rurale
c'est un pays assez assz rural qui
finalement accepte oui le régime des
talibans ne veut pas vraiment changer
oui et pu donc est-ce que finalement
nous on a aussi un un regard sur les
grandes villes sur Kabou où
effectivement il y a eu une émancipation
et et heureusement mais mais est-ce que
ça n'a pas conc concerné finalement une
petite partie de ce pays absolument et
c'est pour cette raison que les talbents
vont pas discuter parce que d'où vient
leur soutien de la population rurale
massivement parce que leur doctrine est
en accord avec les vieilles lois
tribales patri
donc oui oui petoun c'est pas uniquement
les pachetoun de toute façon il y a le
pachetoun mais les autres finalement
quand on regarde de très près c'est pas
beaucoup mieux donc ils ont l'accord de
toute cette population rurale et donc
s'ils commenceent à changer à accepter
des droits pour les femmes ben ils vont
se retrouver sans ce qu'on appellerait
ailleurs un électorat qu'on app
le ça rejoint un peu ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure sur un régime dictatorial
mais qui cherche aussi aussi a pas
totalement se coupé de sa population
mais alors je vais je vais mettre les
pieds dans le plat pardon mais
finalement si c'est ce que veulent les
talibans pourquoi on enfin voilà c'est
pas non mais voz on a déjà essayé
combien de pays ont essayé d'intervenir
là-bas je je dis pas qu'il faut laisser
les femmes afghanes à leur sort mais bon
la question c'est si c'est ce que veut
la population hein bien la population
afghane dans son ensemble la population
traditionnelle la population dans les
villages la population masculine dans
les villages parce que je reste persuadé
qu'une femme dans un village même sielle
a vécu depuis tout sous cette tradition
là de nonexistence parce que les femmes
dans les villages c'est moins que les
chèvres aux yeux de certains hommes donc
considérer une chèvre peut avoir plus de
valeur quand même donc si vous voulez
donc vous nous dites parce que j'ai fait
un l'sus dans ma question c'est si c'est
ce que veut la population une grande
partie de la population traditionnelle
oui alors moi je ne crois qu'à une chose
effectivement donc il faut maintenir une
forme quand même d'assistance
internationale parce qu'il faut quand
même pas laisser ses ses enfants et ses
petites filles vendu échanger pour pour
nourrir les gens mais je je je ne pense
pas qu'on qu'on puisse discuter avec eux
gagnero avoir quoi que ce soit le ils
changeront le jour où la population sera
mécontente le jour où les les les les
minorités chit à zé par exemple ou ou
d'autres et les Tadic commenceront à à
bouger et et même parmi les pachetou
aussi alors d'où l'importance de
l'éducation et de ce que vous faites
carolman parce que vous malgré la
situation vous réussissez je veux bien
que vous nous expliquiez comment à à
maintenir une sorte d'éducation secrète
c'est ça pour des pour des petites
filles comment fa pour ne pas dire
clandestine ben voilà en fait l'arrêt de
l'éducation secondaire a eu lieu bien
avant ce que vous aviez dit alors ma
petite
association qui travaille avec une autre
qui s'appelle nayestan on a mis en place
des écoles disons
parallèles des lieux d'apprentissage
temporaire c'est ce qu'on met sur les
papiers mais en faisant travailler les
anciennes institutrices et des jeunes
filles qui qui ont des diplômes elle ell
rassembl les filles chez elles à à
domicile mais on a de notre côté les
pères de famille parce qu'elle voit
soudain que l'éducation c'est rentable
puisque ces fillesl on les paye on paye
le loyer on paye même des cours
supplémentaires pour elle plein de
choses et les et les parents d'élèves se
disent tiens c'est pas une mauvaise idée
c'est rentable surtout quand on crève de
faim et et de l'autre côté bah les FA am
des enseignantes les soutiennent pour
ces ces raisonsl donc on a près de 3000
élèves maintenant et c'est absolument
extraordinaire on arrive à faire ça où
sont situé vos écoles un peu partout
dans tout le pays pas seulement dans les
grandes villes pas seulement dans les
grandes villes donc a ça rejoint ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure il y a une
appétence quand même pour l'éducation
pour pour sortir de ce statut femmes
mais absolument c'est pourquoi quand on
parle de la population afghane qui ne
veut pas je je sais pas très bien je
crois que la résistance viendra par
l'éducation et viendra par les femmes ou
oui mais quand tout à l'heure dans
l'interview qui a ouvert notre débat
Amad Massou disait il y a 43 millions de
résistants pas
vraiment plus je crois pas que c'est sa
formule ou sa façon de de gérer la
résistance qui va vraiment mener à grand
chose un plédoyer PRODOMO mais mais
c'est pas forcément le reflet
effectivement de la situation effet
vra si d'autres associations s'associent
à nous parce que là on a fait le plein
et avec nos petits moyens on arrivera à
quelque chose mais par rapport au
effectivement au aux écoles clandestines
excusez-moi du terme qui existaiit déjà
sous les talibans la les talibans
première version la situation
aujourd'hui est différente parce
qu'aujourd'hui comme vous l'avez dit les
femmes et même les pères ont avec les
réseaux sociaux ont vu ce qui se passait
dans le monde et donc la pétence au
changement est plus important ente mais
là encore dans les catégories les plus
ouvertes qui regardent les réseaux
sociaux qui qui écoutent les chansons
qui ét ça dans les familles les plus
traditionnelles ça n'existe pas alors je
vis qu'on parle de de la situation
économique d'abord je vais vous donner
des chiffres quand même parce qu'on
parle de la dictature des des talibans
bon ce sont aussi évidemment des
opposants qui ont été arrêtés exécutés
pour certains sens jugement la source
c'est l'ONU qui nous parle d'au moins
218 exécutions extra judiciaire en 2 ans
qui touche d'anciens fonctionnaires des
membres des forces de sécurité afghan
qui ont été donc exécutés sans être jugé
Patricia lmonère est-ce que ceux qui ont
travaillé par exemple avec les
Américains ou avec le régime présent ou
avec des médias occidentaux est-ce
qu'ils sont aussi visés ah oui quand on
dès les mouvements les dès que la France
a même annoncé son retrait avant avant
les autres nos
interprètes étit recevaiit des menaces
mais même quand il travaillaient déjà
avec nous il ils étaient menacés et s
souvent c'était quelqu'un de Kandar qui
se retrouvait au Tadjikistan
ou proche de la frontière oubeek qui
travaillit non pour dans un
endroit très loin de de l'endroit où il
habitait parce que déjà déjà les menaces
étai fortes donc aujourd'hui il y a eu
beaucoup d'exécution extrajudiciaaires
alors que les talibans souvenez-vous
avaient promis une amnistie he oui ou
David R il y il y
a une opposition politique qui visible
qui existe encore ou c'est c'est c'est
totalement surréaliste ce que je dis non
mais il y a rien a rien ri c'est le
problème mais il peut pas y avoir comp
tenu du du régime qui est en place il
peut pas y avoir l'expression on voit
bien la moindre expression à caractère
politique ou même culturel alors j'ai
posé la question différemment est-ce que
au sein du régime des taliban il y a des
lignes qui s'opposent ça c'est autre
chose oui oui il y a il y a des lignes
différentes mais c'est pas on va pas
dire que c'est un débat démocratique
c'est c'est effectivement des lignes qui
sont notamment par exemple entre le
ministre de l'Intérieur Sira jaani par
rapport à àou kunzada qui lui veut
absolument normer la société à tous les
niveaux donc il y a des où il y a il y a
des nuances il y a des nuances
effectivement notamment parce que
certains membres du gouvernement
considèrent que par exemple
l'aostracisation systématique de
l'agende féminine peut avoir un coout
économique induit que il y a la question
de la reconnaissance qui est importante
alors que d'autres considère que ça n'a
pas lieu d'être et cetera donc oui il y
a il y a des nuances effectivement mais
mais pas au sens où nous on considérait
que c'est un débat démocratique
politique tel qu'on peut le concevoir en
Occident vous vous parliez de de la
famille Tam de de 6 million de personnes
qui étaient touchées par la la famille
cette misère elle pousse certaines
familles à vendre leurs filles par
exemple jamaille elle a 21 ans elle a
six enfants elle a perdu son emploi avec
l'arrivée des talibans on en parlait
elle n'a plus de quoi nourrir sa famille
pas Badel pour son bébé elle a
finalement accepté la mort dans l'âme de
vendre trois de ses filles on écoute
jamaille a consenti à
[Musique]
l'indicible sous la pression de son mari
elle a vendu trois de ses
filles
Jamila
Karima et spog
ma la dernière à 2
ans une pratique très ancrée en
Afghanistan surtout au sein des familles
vulnérables et qui s'intensifie ces
derniers
mois alors on vient de vendre la petite
c'est de là je les ai vendu il y a un
petit moment elles resteront quelques
années avec nous en attendant que les
familles viennent les prendre on les a
vendu pour soigner la blessure de mon
père qui a été blessé d'une balle à la
tête j'ai pris 30000 AFG pour
[Musique]
celle afghan l'équivalent de 300 € le
prix d'une
vie les petites seront emmené au moment
de leur
[Musique]
puberté depuis que je les ai vendu je ne
dors plus la nuit je me demande si j'ai
vraiment fait
ça personne ne veut jeter ses enfants
dans une maison inconnue peut-être une
mauvaise
maison je ne dors plus du tout j'ai fait
ça parce que je n'avais pas d'autre
choix voilà extrait de de ce film signé
Soline chalvon fioritier je vous le
rappelle sera sera diffusé sur notre
antenne le 25 novembre prochain Carol
Mann que est-ce que c'est pas
nouveau c'est pas nouveau est-ce que
c'est ça fait partie de de la culture
afghane est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'il faut
dire ça oui mais la culture n'excuse pas
tout bien sûr je une excuse la jeunesse
de la mère elle a pe maximum 20 ans ouis
elle a 21 ans 21 ans oui oui elle a eu 6
enfants oui oui je oui et ça c'est très
fréquent et c'est je crois pas qu'elle
je crois effectivement quand en est très
malheureuse c'est une solution
inextrémiste ouis mais qui est
épouvantable pour nous mais même pour
eux donc parler d'une tradition vendre
les filles oui parce que la dotte la
dote est payée euh à la famille enfin
c'est le mari qui paye euh qui paye la
famille de la fille il y a même un nom
pour ça Shir bah qui veut dire le prix
du lait c'est comme si on achetait une
vache en fait c'est les droits de
reproduction enfin c'est la capacité de
reproduction et de travail on vend donc
la vache la femme de cette façonlà mais
que ces enfants soient aussi petit aussi
jeune oui j'ai déjà vu ça par exemple
des des secondes ou 3è épouses ça donc
ça arrivait pas officiellement mais ça
arrivait quand même donc les familles
n'était pas fier mais pour de l'argent
on vendait des petites filles qui
violaient avant la puberté ça faut
l'ajouter donc c'est absolument
épouvantable mais c'est c'est le produit
de la misère h la vente dans la mesure
où c'est le système de la dote bon ça
c'est classique mais cet âge làà la
jeunesse le fait que ce soit des enfants
c'est c'est ça qui est absolument
horrible et qui est un symptôme de la
misère Patricia lemonè vous l'avez vu en
Afghanistan en reportage vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que pour certains hommes
euh voilà une chèvre vaut plus que la
deuxème ou la trè épouse c'est ça
exctement ouais c'est ça mais ce qui est
la pratique qui se développe aujourd'hui
c'est que effectivement c'est des
enfants qui qui sont violés enc avant la
puberté c'est-à-dire que l'échange de
l'enfant se fait quand il a peut-être 2
ans mais très très vite mettant une
qu'Ant une petite fille qui a 4 ans à 7
ans elle part et et à 7 ans elle est
violée les enfants violés à 7 ans les
petites filles viol à 7 ans c'est
courant maintenant et ça l'était déjà
mais ça ne fait que effectivement
s'accentuer aujourd'hui et son don sur
effectivement la place de la femme quand
même dans cette société mais il faut
voir que cette jeune femme qui a dû
avoir son premier enfant peut-être à 10
ans je ne sais pas souvent ces mères là
sont drogué en plus et quand j'ai vu son
regard outre le fait que la fatigue je
me disais je suis persuadé qu'en plus
elle prend de la drogue et moi des mères
de famille que j'ai que j'ai pu
rencontrer euh et interview effectiv
chaque fois c'est que des femmes qui
peuvent les les interviewer et bien étai
drogué toutes pour tenir elles étaient
obligées elle ne tenait que comme ça et
donc le peu d'argent qu'elles avaient
elle le dépensait là-dedans ENF c'est un
cercle qu'on ne peut même pas même pas
imaginer David rigol rose est-ce qu'il y
a une ENF parce que là personne n'a
d'alternative n'a de solution évidemment
sur ce plateau
mais peut y avoir une alternative
politique au au taliban dans les dans
les prochaines années pas dans
l'immédiat malheureusement euh c'est le
problème c'est c'est un processus long
c'est comme pour l'éducation c'est c'est
un Paris sur le futur
euh qui paraît ingras actuellement mais
qui l'est pas parce que c'est un travail
de fond simplement non dans l'immédia
malheureusement il y aura pas donc ça
veut dire que pardon interrompe il faut
maintenir une forme d'aide humanitaire
parce que c'est malgré tout minimal
parce que ça peut être aussi l'occasion
de faire passer d'autres valeurs
d'autres messages est-ce que vous pensez
ça une des erreurs et de l'échec de
l'intervention occidentale c'est d'avoir
cru et là je reprends ce que vous disiez
sur
l'ethnocentrisme c'est c'est d'avoir cru
qu'on pouvait changer un monde une
société en 20 ans c'est pas possible
malheureusement ce serait formidable
mais ça l'est pas et en fait c'est des
processus sont des processus longs et
donc notamment j'ai j'ai été frappé par
certaines ONG scandinav qui à l'époque
voulait absolument aller dans les
villages et voulait qu'il a une égalité
homme femme
strict donc c'était une humiliation pour
les chefs de village et et donc ça
suscitait un rejet en fait et donc c'est
ça a été contre-productif à terme il
aurait fallu que ça soit beaucoup plus
progressif plus transactionnel et et du
coup effectivement on arrive à la
situation où les talibans reviennent au
pouvoir en rétablissant ce qu'ils
avaient déjà instauré précédemment Carol
man comment on peut vous aider pour
aider les femmes afghanes et bien
écoutez contribuer au travail qu'on fait
je voudrais rajouter une chose c'est il
faut voir le programme scolaire qui va
s'appliquer aux garçons où on a enlevé
tout ce qui est tout ce qui paraît
physique chimie et toute référence à à
des inventions n'importe
quoiage oui qui non mais qui sont part
des non musulmans h donc on laisse
tomber la relativité la gravité ENF tout
donc je crois qu'il faudra réfléchir à
un programme également pour les garçons
parce que ce sont pas uniquement les
filles qui sont menacé donc ça je crois
que on peut nous aider mais on aide la
planète finalement parce que quand on
regarde bon je vais parler d'autres
choses la montée de la droite la
l'acceptation de pays comme l'Arabie
Saoudite et morale de ce genre il faut
aider l'éducation et voilà donc toute
personne qui est intéressée par ça nous
contacte on on vous dira comment faire
voilà ce sera le dernier message de ce
débat merci à tous d'y avoir participé
patri je rappelle le titre de votre
livre j'en conseille vivement la lecture
au cœur du chaos aux éditions
to voilà c'est la fin de ce sens public
merci à tous d'y avoir participé je vous
dis à lundi on se retrouvera à 18h et
22h sur l'antenne de public sénna et
puis notterz que demain c'est agès Busin
ancien ministre de la Santé qui sera
l'invité Doriane
Mancini